what up guys welcome to the pre-game
[Music]
uh before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell the way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos okay
guys as you already know all right first
off welcome to all the new subscribers
this week i know a bunch of you are new
here um we do this show three times a
week so make sure you turn on your
notifications you're notified every time
that we're live
while you're at it all super chats are
going to be read by the panel so if you
have something you want our opinions on
send a super chat and we will read it
the other thing is guys
as you know our sponsor is cooking with
chris if you guys want to lose weight
with foods that you already like okay
all you do is you give this guy the
foods that you already like to eat and
he makes you a customized meal plan with
the nutrients that you need in a given
day so that is our channel sponsor
okay so guys
why don't we start but everyone say your
name your age your relationship status
and where you're from okay my name is
ini my relationship is i'm married and
i'm from the uk
i'm josh
i'm josh from nottingham uk uh i got a
girlfriend and
let's buy it
my name is anaya i am 25 years old i'm
from new york slash brazil and um i have
a boyfriend
i am louisa i'm 22 i'm from southeast
and i am single
i am ish
i'm 26 i'm from east london essex and i
am single
okay so
the topic of the day is we're talking
about
women proposing to met
so i want to hear from the girls and the
guys from the girls i want to know would
you ever propose to a guy and from the
guys i want to know would you accept a
proposal from a woman
so why don't you start what's always
though yeah okay so the question first
question is
no no it's just one question would you
accept a proposal from a woman okay i'm
already married already so no okay yeah
but like hypothetically alphabetically
probably not because it just sets the
dynamics of the relationship in a
awkward way because she's setting the
lead
and
maybe this may sound controversial but i
don't believe
women
can
take the lead in the relationship
because
long term that's going to disturb the
dynamics and obviously bring some
long-term
issues and stuff so yeah i don't think
so
okay
me i'm here for it if you're going to
propose to me like it feels like it's
the right time get down on that one
like we 20 22 is equal rights right here
so like she loves me the same as i meant
to love her than like
get down i mean for me i see it's like
confidence as well like
that's ballsy so like anything like i'll
get taken back like i got respect to
respect and move like that's a power
player you don't think it seems like
desperate
nah that's just confidence like that's
the same like if you're saying if girl
makes the first move it's like like
desperate like it's just confidence
marriage
marriage your first move two different
two different ball games yeah you
control the relationship doesn't matter
i think that's fine
that's fine
i feel like the man is the breadwinner
he's the head of the family so
i'm not even gonna go there okay
[Music]
literally because imagine he says no now
what am i going to do oh hell no no no
you're getting a little closer
no you can't i can't go through all that
effort and then you say no
if it says no you just gotta keep it
moving no you took a l bounce back you
know
in the first place but you have to
remember no we women don't take
rejection that well
yeah we're usually not used to rejection
yeah nah and i appreciate that but i'm
saying like that is a huge problem like
if you choose to get down on that one
knee and you take it oh like you're
gonna move on i wouldn't want to be with
a guy that would let me do that
because like
because i just as you want to be with a
guy that takes the lead yeah
but as a guy as well as a guy like if
someone gets down on one ear saying you
don't want to be a weird guy that will
let you do that yeah like as a guy how
do you stop that like you see him
getting down and you're like
i mean you you you're very clear with
the intention of the relationship where
it's going
but you can say like you were clarified
with dane for marriage but then you
haven't popped the question yet i would
say this so to give uh women a bond i
think you can give indication give
strong hints or just talk about it yeah
but i don't but i do agree the man has
to initiate because the problem is if
you set that
that foundation
long term is going to bring a lot of
toxic dynamics in the relationship and
let's face it as men we can become lazy
if you know
yeah it'd be like oh she's paying all
the bills she's supposed to be the boss
babe i can sit down and play xbox all
day
yeah so
what about you would you
um
no i wouldn't accept marriage proposal
from a woman um i think it's
imperative for a guy to
be ready financially mentally absolutely
um in order for him to kind of commit to
something like that and
it sets the president that
man's not in control of his house and
like if the guy's not ready to do that
then yeah it shouldn't it just looks so
desperate from the girls like it's like
um have you ever seen those girls that
basically strong harm their boyfriend
into marrying them and you could tell he
did not want to marry you he's just he
just didn't want you to
[Music]
i'm not leave i'm not saying like i
might have sat on the first date talking
like
yo by the way like i need you to like
get down on one knee like that's not the
same but let's say like you're five
years in whatever situations i've got to
whatever situation i've got to
she gets down on one knee like you're
not expecting it she just does it like
at that moment right there i'm not going
to instantly think like you know what
she's a [ __ ]
yeah i see where you're coming from but
don't you feel that you as the man
should upset yeah initiative set the
environment because what happens is
let's say for example you do accept the
proposal you do get married who's making
the decision
what are we going to do if something
goes wrong who's going to make the
mortgage who's going to pay the bills
who's responsible for this and that
just just because she has done a one
knee yeah does that mean she's running
it sets the trend you see and that's
what's gonna happen in your relationship
believe me believe me i think if you're
really gonna pattern saying like if the
way you're gonna pass and the way you're
gonna like carry on is like the way it's
gonna be so like just because she gets
down on one knee doesn't mean like she's
gonna pass her from there because you
can you can set pace straight but if you
look at the rules if you set the
foundation that oh you can lead blah
blah blah what will happen is she will
be frustrated with you and be resentful
and once a woman's resentful that's when
she's open to she
emotionally
i mean if yeah
that's how you feel it that's how you
feel like
the women agree with me on that one my
habit their reaction
yes
i just feel like conversations like that
should be spoken about 100 there's no
point of going into something that long
and have not had that conversation
absolutely
yeah
yeah yeah
even in the first like two years that's
something yes
but when you say when you say have that
conversation do you mean it's like have
the conversation saying i'm about to
propose to you in this amount of time
what's the purpose
so so if after two three years he says
like we're going to get married like the
only place i see us going is getting
married so you're like act cool but then
like two years down the lane
you're not married yet or he hasn't got
down on one yeah yeah
yeah yeah and i'm gonna tell you what's
good yeah
he's not showing leadership because if
he's gonna say he's gonna do it you've
got to set the trend it's not you can't
wait for the woman to be like oh you
said the trend and i would do it it's
not going to work because that just sets
a bad scene you know
yeah i think another aspect to it is
like if you're a guy and you'd be
classed as the hunter in your
relationship and you're looking for your
woman
does it make sense for her to pick you
or for her to make the initiation to say
i want you to be my person essentially
if i'm the hunter i want to pick my prey
in that kind of scenario so i don't
really want it to be a case where she's
said oh i want to be you no i may not
want you i feel that situation i think
the way like
you might say marriage is like you
already haven't been picked like
if the girl on my side like she's
already been picked like i've already
done my picking yeah like you're welcome
like here we go let's move forward like
me saying now
all right we're gonna get married for me
like doesn't make her more my woman or
less my woman like she's still been made
my woman so like that whole getting
married i don't think for me personally
anyway it's like i'm picking her more or
less it's more just like
having a big ceremony
getting away with a couple boys on
enjoying that makes sense
so
um would you either of you consider
yourself like a feminist
that's a good question i don't know i
don't know i don't know i don't really
think so
it's not every guy that's going to open
every single door for me in every single
place i don't really think
i don't think so either okay
it's just well it's just interesting
because like i feel like a lot of times
we want equality but only for like the
things that benefit us
but not not like really like like not
where we would propose or we would take
the guys out on the date
don't even get started
yeah
so it's just like it's interesting you
know what i mean like you never hear
like you never hear women talk about
like the stuff that doesn't benefit us
um
like what
there's a lot of things that benefit
women mm-hmm that's the statement i'm
going with
i think that i think the question is
like for example you don't see the
feminists complaining the lack of
representation in you know women in the
coal mines digging up calls i've never
had plumbers bricklayers yes exactly
sewage cleaners
um how long do you guys think is too
long to wait for a proposal
for y'all yeah
well i feel like when a guy starts
dating you
he
will kind of know if he wants to go
further with you as into marriage you
all know that from the beginning yeah
six months that's true that's true to be
with you for a certain amount of time
as a potential wife yeah that's true
i feel like for me i can date somebody
for two years
and then in that time we're already
talking about where is this going i'm
very straightforward i don't have a
problem
for the first time
like you like me i like you you're cute
whatever i want to know you but what is
your actual intention with me um so i
feel like two years
year and a half two years especially
depending on also the age of the yeah
let's let's say over over 22 over the
age of 22. three years i'll say is it a
long time to know some words
personally but i feel like maybe three
or four years then just that mark
roughly yeah i definitely could i feel
like
after two years i'd be like what what's
what's the hold up
i'm like i'm
gonna go really quick on the
conversation you're having with your
partner yeah and the stability you have
exactly like how old are you is the guy
financially stable is he going through
the financial in two
years he even have the type of money
that he can you know put into the
wedding or anything else like the house
the children eventually the children
anything else um is he taking care of
his mom on the side or what's going on
you know all of that is a big factor
nothing possible people forget when
they're thinking into marriage
the person you're actually marrying my
family
so you could be vibing with the person
but have a terrible relationship with
their in-laws and then that's the
problem especially when children come
into the business yeah just gone like
yeah because you haven't had that kind
of conversation expose them to yourself
would you dump somebody if you didn't
like their family no if they didn't like
no no if you didn't like their family go
around
it would be a bit it would have been a
by the way i do love my in-laws by the
way
if that was a potential banana skin
possibly not because that would bring
that distress because it works when
christmas comes and the family first
you're thinking this is too stressful
and kids come they have to have that
relationship with that in-law and stuff
like that so
i think it's a big consideration because
i think what happens is when you're
looking for a relationship you're just
looking for that romantic feeling does
that other person give me that vibe but
you don't think long term
do i get along with the in-laws with
every time we go in i'm gonna have an
argument all the time and that's gonna
i'm gonna bring that frustration to my
spouse and that's going to damage our
relationship so these are the things
that need to be considered
me therma
goes with the flow if me and the girls
are cool like that's it like it's me and
her bonnie and clyde don't mind anything
else
okay what about you guys um i feel like
it would depend like if i try to make it
work and they're still not allowing that
relationship to flourish then i think i
wouldn't want to be there either but
otherwise i guess it would really depend
i like to try i have to try to work
things out yeah
right right
yeah um for me um i agree with the
trying that's a really good thing but um
i feel like i
i'm too big on family for that i don't
think i could firm it just knowing that
you know that part of our relationship
isn't fulfilled yeah so i didn't think i
would yeah i would do that
um i think it would depend on how badly
it affected our internal relationship
like i would factor in so many different
things to be like all right
if this is making
her unhappy
because
of what her family think of me
then i would like say look we're
probably best off
not continuing but i would want to
pursue it to see how far if i could make
it better through time yeah that's cool
so
what do you think are some of the
reasons that modern relationships are
failing today we see like i think it's
close to it's close to uh
it's close to like a 50 divorce rate
um and then you see a lack of marriage
as well
and the average um
time someone gets divorced is after
eight years
so
i'll say so i'll correct you on that
stat about divorces it's first-time
marriages it's not it's first-time
marriages are actually quite high it's
because in the divorce statistics people
they include second and third marriages
and what happens is if you have been
divorced once you're likely to you're
right
right
right
so do you know the actual number uh
in terms of first marriages
not as high as we may think it is i
think it only bumps up to like like 60
70 percent yeah if you factor that in
yeah so i don't i don't think it's it's
still like one and four yeah still there
but right okay it's not like 50 percent
yeah no but the other problem is you're
not factoring in the people that don't
get married at all yeah and like half of
women in their 30s are single and
childless
so that's tough
so why do you guys think that modern
relationships are failing today i've got
a theory
why that's the case i think when you
consider a relationship i always use the
um the three r's when you're focusing on
one so you use the rational side
you know is that person
compatible in terms of are they in debt
you know what's the financial status
what's their prospects where they get
along with their in-laws does the other
side that's the romantic side
the vibe the feeling does that person
give me butterflies that sort of thing
and also you got the what i would say is
the religious side do you share the same
values yeah got to consider those free
if one's missing that's potentially what
happens what tends to happen is most
coppers focus on the romantic side oh
we've we're vibing whatever happens
we're gonna get through it marriage
don't run on board yeah
the rational side or the spiritual side
yeah and those are so important so i say
if the three are not in that component
it's
it's a high probability
that's good oh good point
i mean
i brought this up but not um a time
before another major thing like is
society and social media yes
a lot of people are gallowing jumping on
the internet yeah a lot of people are
easy access over the internet so
being in a relationship and having that
much access to different people every
day
is going to play a big factor
yeah yeah yeah
a male or female boy oh i both yeah
these days um yeah both it's like a
little kid in a candy shop oh these
choices what do i do
but any other reasons i guess that
depends on your character as well yeah
and what you're doing as well yeah but i
think it's always the same
bad company corrupts good character
sooner or later no matter how firm you
think you are if you're surrounded by a
company it will influence you we're not
superman or super women
i like that one too
you got knowledge you know
i think women have changed though as
well
personally
i think
like
just women move different to how they
used to like well when i say you
seriously i don't know why they used to
move like but i think
like what's ex maybe like more more
sociably acceptable for women is like
maybe it's similar to what guys do maybe
it's not similar to what guys do but i
just think it's like
girls are moving crazy out here is it
that though i will say this i will say
this though i think it's always been in
there
the there's always toxic toxicity in
both male and females what's happening
social media just exposed it the mistake
we make is that social media has made
people more toxic no it's just revealed
what was already in there maybe it's
revealed it but it's also made it like
cute
girls like will say little like toxic
things i was like
cute things like
oh i'll slash those tires like little
laughing face and be like oh you're so
cute yeah what they've done in history
i've done that you've heard of the
notion jezebel
from the old testament that she was a
she was a queen to a king called ahab
that would be our version of a beta ml
she was the one that was he he she would
say oh king will come and say oh i can't
do this and jezebel would say go kill
him so there's always that innate toxic
nature
to do that you see so all i'm just
saying is that all social medias does
just reveal the toxicity in the human
heart
there's a famous word that says the
heart is deceitful above all things and
desperately wicked you can know it
get him yeah
i'm a big distraction as well yeah
instead of you focus on the things that
you need to focus on like that's a big
distraction because we're coming into a
digital world now so yeah everything
yeah everything you do
online well it's kind of like
even normal stuff like the nhs and
checkups and stuff don't just do it go
online yeah i'm not
toxicity for males is aggression
toxicity for females is manipulation
that's the worst kind when you say it
both are abnormal both are toxic
aggressive men are scary yeah and little
men are scary
women are scared they're just harder to
suss
my brother curtis come on
i think women are worse than men today
yes yes maybe women are just a bit more
sly my corner's been lonely for this
whole chat so i'm glad
we call um like for example
you've mentioned this a lot in in in the
past it's like for example let's say a
man and a woman have a custody battle
they've divorced and they're trying to
get a custody theme so for example
they're in court
and let's say the they're examining the
woman to say that you're not fit you've
done this you've done that and because
when a woman becomes emotional they
start crying and crying ultimately think
is sympathy she's telling the truth but
if they question the same thing to a man
the man becomes aggressive they go like
oh why are you aggressive you must be a
bully that's how they lose i don't think
men are overly aggressive today i think
they're more feminine yeah i think i
think i think men are more girly today
like to be honest
because i mean but how can they not be
upgraded but like how can they not be
there's a lack of like like
half of kids growing up didn't have a
dad in the home yeah so it's like yeah
yeah so where are they gonna of course
of course they're gonna be and also the
media gives you um
yeah and when you do
you're weak yeah be a man i'm like what
else are you gonna do
you know i remember when i was in my
when i was like college this was about
12 years ago i was thinking
what does it mean to be a man if i
um claims to be typical mr nice guy and
i used to be roasted all over and i
remember i was sort of dating a girl at
college at the time and she told me and
i was in love with this girl
and she said to me so okay i've done
everything for you i do this i would
bait her as
everything
and she said uh but you like a bit of
edge you're nice but you like a bit of
edge i think what
what she meant was a backbone a backbone
yes exactly
yeah because you don't want to date a
guy that doesn't have a bag
i feel like guys just need to learn how
to like express themselves properly
maturely in a way a female can
understand and not be like yo what the
hell is you doing you know what i mean
it's not like a cry yeah but that's
that's asking guys to be more feminine
though if you're if you're saying no if
you're if you're saying i mean like yeah
that's with the backbone thing it's like
you able to do that
can i have an example so i just maybe
we're talking about the same thing so
example of like how like how you would
do that just like express yourself in a
way that i can clearly understand you
like i'm not trying to hear no text
about oh remember what you did no i'm
trying to hear you want to meet me face
to face to talk about our issues
okay yeah but that for like so what
you're saying obviously like that
whatever that may be like that might be
different for you yeah different to
another girl different to another i say
like
then the way again a man's gonna have to
then come across to you and that is all
based on what he thinks is the right way
to come across to you so then that's
still up in the air
the way he might come across to you is
the way he's thinking is the right way
or maybe previously with another girl is
the way she wanted yeah but then again
it's still down to communication yeah
but even with that understanding your
partner as well yeah both you have to
remember
it's more easier for a woman to put her
thoughts and feelings into words and it
is for us guys yeah we can't naturally
do that so i think you're trying to
judge a pig how to fly
no you see sometimes
you said you said yeah
right you're looking for a male that can
communicate however
not communicate but have clarity have
integrity i would say that
we've got to define our words you want a
man with integrity he says what he says
it means what he means
that's what he means so when he
communicates he says that i'm gonna do
this he's gonna do this when he says
that i'm gonna know but it's about how
he's feeling not what he's doing no he's
doing it trust me action's gonna be
louder than words trust me i'm sorry i'm
not feeling um
can i can i like what i need an example
from you so i know what you're talking
about so like like can i have an example
of a situation where a guy didn't do
like do it correctly
no it doesn't have to be a real one you
can make it up
where he didn't do what like like
express his feelings
communicate clearly
um
[Music]
maybe in a situation where um
they felt like things were one-sided and
i didn't see it that way
okay so like i wasn't able to kind of
like understand how he felt in the
situation where he felt everything was
one-sided so like he felt like he was
doing everything and he didn't he never
communicated that to you yeah exactly
and told you that so how are you
supposed to how are you feeling what you
want me to do and where we're going
wrong okay how do guys how do you guys
interpret that have you ever felt like
that i think what would mean i've come
to this conclusion and this is what i've
learned
the notion of 50 50 doesn't work in a
relationship so as a man i've got to say
as the leader of my household i've got
to say everything that goes wrong is on
me
oh my god no she's like i like this
i'm responsible for setting the
environment so for example i hear a lot
of uh guys in the red pool saying i need
a woman to submit
but i'm saying do you create the
environment for her to feel safe to
submit to you first
yeah
yeah and that's what i'm saying because
i'll say you've got to correct that
environment you see because there's no
point in me don't mind the submission
she doesn't respect me
but you also shouldn't be with a guy
that like you can't submit to
yeah yeah so so like a lot of girls will
waste the dude's time when they know
damn well they just like
the guy is the guy's fault for not
setting that boundary you're right he
needs to because he's more logical right
but i'm gonna put like accountability on
both people yeah like
because some guys like don't know any
better and you feel kind of bad for them
to be honest that's my mission to make
men
i don't really feel bad for them and the
reason why is because i think there's
certain boundaries that they haven't set
and they've allowed women to step over
them yeah they put boundaries and
perimeters in place to ensure that this
doesn't happen yeah or they have like
self-respect for themselves
then
these things won't happen
even if it's at the detriment that
they're gonna lose that girl that
they're talking to it's like at least
you have your dignity like stick with
what you've got yeah but the problem is
they haven't had a model for them to to
copy most men so for example they get
their
notion of matters from feminists or from
soap operas and the way they
dismasculate men that's terrible
because because they tell they tell men
they want them to be more emotional and
like feeling and all this stuff but no
you don't
no you don't have a dude if a dude cries
to me every like two weeks
i'm the girl like
i'm the one on my period
i am married now i came to my wife and
said to her honey we're broke and i
started crying trust me she's going to
lose respect for me
immediately immediately what she wants
to hear from me is that okay you've got
the problem but i want to see you in the
process of fixing this stuff yes she's
more calm yeah i can't say to her
i'm a failure
and all the men you respect the most
they don't they're not out here crying
like my dad's one of the people i
respect more than like anyone on the
planet i've seen him cry twice in my
life like ever like he doesn't
and he doesn't even get mad he's like
the most calm like cool collected person
i know and like it makes you respect
them more
because i just feel like as women like
we're naturally emotional and men are
naturally naturally logical and like
it's oh my god have you ever dated a guy
that's more emotional than you
like it's
oh my god and you're just like
i'm the girl
a little bit sometimes you know if i
feel like i can't you say that now you
say that now
but if i i'm not saying every single day
but let me allow me to comfort you on
one side i feel like it's sad that guys
can't really cry in front of us because
they should be able to but then on the
other side women i guess wouldn't
respect them as much yeah can i
sorry can i rebuttal that as well like
just or even add to that the reason why
i think men should go to other men about
their problems
and they shouldn't be shut down by the
other guys exactly
bro why are you crying yeah i agree no i
i i totally agree with you
yeah yeah but i have that as well
because i have my pastor so for example
if i'm going through an emotional thing
for example i'm going for a step of
depression or i'm just feeling
overwhelmed i can go to a man some man
cry in front of him and you know sort it
out and you can teach me like a man's
okay this is what you need
and stuff like that for example these
quite essential alpha and my opinion is
jesus christ and he
wept
so he can't weep for the good things not
all the time but know when to do it
there's a right time to do it not a rock
the problem is we do things in the wrong
place at the wrong time you can't weep
all the time you gotta sometimes go okay
i've worked let the emotion out now deal
with it deal with the problem and as
i've become older i've actually realized
i actually when i see problems i see the
more opportunities to grow
i feel like the only time you respect a
guy crying as if he's tough all the time
and you're the only one that's seen him
cry like i feel like i feel like that's
the only time where you're like yeah
like and something's really yeah oh my
gosh this is how my dad convinced me
never to smoke again
because one of the times i saw my dad
cry i smoked weed like once in high
school
and literally my dad found out and he
like cried because i feel like that
generation just looks at it kind of
differently
and like when oh my god i was so i was
i was so disappointed
he was so mad at me and it was funny
well they thought i was a stoner i was
like i've literally done it once
[Music]
but it wasn't like i lost respect for my
dad then but because my dad's always
been like stoic my whole life you know
what i mean
but oh my god i can't relate
no he's no why in terms of like a father
figure like my
dad dad i can't relate but in terms of
like my stepdad he is a rock like
there's different kind of step that's
big upstairs 100 but it's just like
there's different role models when it
comes to male figures
i've only seen my dad not cry
but i guess be very very sad when his
mother died
um that was the only time yeah there
have been other situations but he is
just such a rock for both me yeah yeah
and he needs to be he needs to be and
there's only certain periods of time
that a man should cry like for example
like i said death of a loved one
you know or maybe his daughter just
graduated or being married lots of good
crimes and stuff like that yeah he's
crying because of every single problem
happening he sees that he wants to cry
you're like if you can ask me
a protector or if there's a bottle
there's a burglar coming
or it's like oh my gosh the other thing
is when
you feel like the guy can't solve any
problems and you have to like do it
always
and you're just like yeah like you're
not even helping me at this point yeah
like you just
it's like because we look to guys for
like leadership and like guidance and
you want to feel like they're more
competent than you
or at least like logical because
naturally like men are more logical so
oh my gosh have you ever been in a
situation where you felt like you were
like carrying it in that way
um
i feel like i've been in
yeah i think so like it's nothing like
crazy but i wanted to do a certain
course and um i knew that that guy had
the connections i was seeing him at the
time i asked him but he was taking so
long so long he wasn't doing anything he
wasn't doing anything i asked him again
he didn't do anything so i had to
contact that person myself like oh by
the way i'm his
girl mm-hmm did you say he was going to
do it though yeah he did like everything
for me like in a relationship
it's not like doing tests at all but
and he says i'm going to call you back
in five minutes yeah and then it's not
like i'm waiting there but it's like
is he going to call me back yeah it
might seem it might seem like a dumb
thing but for me that's important yeah
are you going to do exactly what you
said yeah or are you going to do
something else yeah
that for me especially in the beginning
kind of determines if i'm going to
respect you or not
it's not like one time he does that but
it's very frustrating when you're with a
guy and it's like you never you never
know if he means what he said
so he promises things he's never is
gonna do it's like then you feel like
you're mothering them yeah and like you
you start to be enough you start to be
in like uh and we shouldn't we shouldn't
do that so like i think that's also on
us like becoming the mother like perfect
like that's not your job you should
leave but like like we shouldn't date
guys you have to mother
but but it's very frustrating as a
female to just like not know if he's
going to do what he says he's going to
do so
at what point do you leave
at what time at what point do you leave
if you see a behavior where he's not
saying what he does
at what point do you go is it the first
time he does it it's when it gets
significant it's a pattern
yeah once it yeah once it becomes a
pattern it's going to be a time a set
date yeah and you can't meet that yeah
once twice no it's fine
so twice
we mentally left you three months ago
at that third strike like i'm probably
already detached
because it's easy like whatever like
but i'm gone already
so
yeah it's kind of sad though
just just do what you say man
just don't do it don't say it if you
can't do it yeah it's easy this is what
i'm saying
depends what it is like some stuff like
it's you just some stuff you just say it
like you literally just say it
like you're literally china you just
haven't done that because someone else
is like
counting on your word yeah exactly i
mean it depends what it is if it says
like you need like 100 pounds or like
you're gonna die it's like all right
yeah like that's important but if it's
like flipping
you're gonna do something then all right
i'll call you back then like
because if you're saying i don't know
next week we're going to go on a trip
and then it doesn't work out you're
probably going to tell the girl like oh
we can't do that specific day i told you
though yeah
yeah i ain't saying like because
obviously you're gonna have
conversations in the meantime so
obviously i might crop up but obviously
that might be a time where you like you
say something small i don't know call
you about maybe do something this time
and then like obviously like two days
down the line it's like oh yeah like
mm-hmm and got it
i would say
not even the same
i will say this though i think also when
things like that happen i agree with you
it is a couple of mistakes the the key
to for the woman to feel safe is the
accountability if he accepts babe i
messed up i apologize i'm gonna make it
up dude xyz and he does that yeah
i
that
sorry no i agree there has to be a
passage
yeah yeah yeah
but if he's a person then you got to say
he's not mature enough to do that
because convince myself
if he's supposed to be the leader of my
family and we have kids
if he's
he can't be faithful with the little
things how can you be faithful with the
big things in life like kids coming
involved they're little things of like
arranging a holiday arranging a debt
date these are little things these are
litmus tests hence why i advocate for
arranged marriages because i don't think
the vetting process i think we can't do
it ourselves
[Music]
i'm actually for arranged marriages i
would i'd be cool with it as long as as
long as as long as they pick somebody
cute they cannot they cannot they cannot
set me up with no ugly guy
every time my parents want to set me up
with someone i'm like i'm like
every time my parents want to set me up
with someone i'm like they're not
before you get started on that yeah you
obviously just said like how you gonna
lie
if they can't do them little things how
they're gonna do the big things
but logic it is but as well but it's
also like uh what's deemed as important
in it so like
someone might see like
talking about some of these minor things
are just so irrelevant like so minor so
like not important that like do them
don't do them it's
ain't that deep where you talk about
some of the big things it's like that's
a priority like maybe that's a child
that's my child or whatever yeah like
it's that deep so it's like that will
get done but we talking about these
other things like yeah
for example before i can think of
building
riding a motorcycle i've gotta first
ride the bike first
so is that that's is that um stage you
see because you would expect someone i
can't ride the bicycle but i can ride
the motorbike it makes no sense the job
is too big you've got to be faithful
with little steps you see this is the
problem with our society we always think
that oh if i get this big if i get this
money now i'll be so responsible but
you're not responsible for spending 20
pounds but yeah you're going to be
responsible you've got 20 million
i don't i don't think people change like
ever i think people get worse over time
i think there's
there's exceptions to the rule there's
definitely exceptions in general in
general i mean like other specific
exceptions sure but like i think most of
the time your childhood friends like
they see you in 10 years you're pretty
much going to be a similar person but
maybe out of shape
there's birth to that though
it's gross if you want to change
somebody you can't if you want to change
yourself yeah they want to change
themselves
i don't know i think most of the time
they just go back to who they are out i
i think most of the time they just go
back to who they were after like a year
or two years or whatever it is i don't
think you would do that
do i think like change and then just go
back
no i think i've been like the person
i've been since i was young i think like
one thing that i did change was i was a
big drinker in college and i stopped
drinking but i'm always
like i'm always going to want to drink
there's always going to be a part of me
that like wants to drink and has that in
me that doesn't change i just change the
behavior
but like i don't think who i am change
like getting drunk is fun as hell
i just don't do it anymore because the
consequence is like it were just
i was trying to be like slim thick you
know what i mean
tip for any relationship always focus on
your responsibility never focus on
another person trying to change every
person because it's gonna be things so
i'm the leader of my household i'm
responsible for it if anything goes
wrong it's down to me i can't go saying
it's my wife's fault what is this for no
it's my responsibility i need to make
stuff work no but there's certain like
girls whatever it is it's like
accountability again you're the same
thing because
your family does pay like play a big
role it does it does yes so you carrying
the weight of every single thing is a
lot not make it i'm making a purposeful
decision because the reason why the
reason why i'm doing that i can only
focus on what i can control okay i can't
control what anyone does in the family i
have to focus on what i can do
[Music]
to work you gotta have a lot of
lubrication a lot of oils and stuff like
that am i doing that in the relationship
am i creating a safe environment for my
wife to submit to me because i see a lot
of people in red bull women don't submit
today women like this women like that
and i'm like
what have you done
to um to level out well because i think
there's
i think there's a generation of men that
are kind of addicted to video games in
corn yep yeah
i think there's a generation of guys
that are well and there's a generation
because we know one in three men under
30 year virgins one in three minutes i i
have i have not like if you got a cat
one of you or or sorry sorry are virgins
or haven't had sex in the past i want to
say it's a year
there might be that caveat but but you
don't understand like
no no i was saying i i was saying one in
three men i don't even know why
no i'm good
no problem
i appreciate that it's not that no no
but it's like there's a a subset of guys
that are very very lonely that like most
people don't even really see because
like i have guys dm me telling me oh i'm
i'm
they give me a lot of problems that i
can't fix for them but like like they'll
be like oh i'm addicted to i'm addicted
to hookers i i haven't like i um i have
never had a girl like me ever show me
any interest in me ever
and i'm like i can't even admit like you
might not have the guys you want
interested in you but as a girl
somebody's gonna like you girls never
have that issue that's true no
but most of us will bang anything a
breeze
[Music]
do you guys think that traditional roles
and responsibilities are imperative to
like a
relationship succeeding
um so like traditional like girl girl
cook stays home with the kids and men
work
i think
is that when i say the word men should
lead
automatically you have a false notion
that that means i'm just giving orders
my notion of leadership is servitude
that says in the old testament in the
new testament you know the the greatest
among you shall be his servant like the
son of man did not come to be sir but to
serve and i think the greatest form of
leadership is servant leadership created
by environment that people want to
submit to you it happens in militaries
in in any sort of military
the commanders that says to his army i'm
not going to even to my troops eat those
ships are going to be so loved about
command that they're willing to die for
it so the key to it is servitude and
once you do that you create loyalty
i heard that
he's got mad boys
[Music]
what do you what do you think
what's the question again i got lost and
i saw a squad
um so do you think that traditional like
gender roles are important in a
relationship to succeed
nah i don't think so personally
i feel like obviously like with
everything that's happening i think like
it's just there's so many layers to that
so it's like obviously like what kind of
role is it like the whole step home
thing like i'm not saying like the girl
needs to like stay at home but saying
like do that but do you think obviously
like
well
everyone's different like there is like
certain people that
are against this but more time i do
think the guy needs to be like
more in control like he needs to
but i just think that's right now i just
think that's how it works i think most
girls
would want that
but maybe like obviously this
you know women equality is coming and
like women empowerment so maybe in like
200 years like we may not look for that
but do you think right now women want a
guy who's gonna like be more maybe like
not controlling but maybe more like like
he said like take the lead so for now
i'll say that yeah yeah okay what do you
guys think um the way i was brought up
was my father man of the house a mom
submitting to him but that's because
like he said he created that safe
environment for her to submit um me
personally
because i've seen
that relationship that type of
relationship i want that for myself but
that doesn't mean that my dad didn't
cook food or he didn't make dinner yeah
he had like bigger responsibilities yeah
outside of the house yeah whereas my mom
had bigger responsibilities inside the
house
so um yeah that's like what i'm striving
for and that's what i tell guys and a
lot of guys they look at me
they're like oh but wait so you want a
job no that doesn't mean my mom worked
she had a job right
independence that's because she wanted
to not because she had to yeah and i've
always said that i said this to my wife
though you're going to work because you
want to not because you have to and it's
my responsibility that you feel safe
that you can relax in your feminine so
when you work you're doing it because oh
if i lose my job i'm going to not pay
the mortgage now that's my job you know
exactly that's a good intake what do you
guys think
i've lost the question too um
are gender roles
yeah important
um i believe so i think having a gender
having gender roles kind of sets uh the
narrative that um this is your
responsibility and what you need to do
and this is my responsibility and what i
need to do yeah yeah
it then gives everyone or holds everyone
clarity and accountability most
importantly like with the gender role it
means um if i'm not
sticking up to my end of the bargain
yeah then you can hold me accountable
for that and
me so too to you yeah so um
at the extreme end where we're talking
about she's
she's not working or she has to do
dishes and you do nothing i don't
believe that that works in this modern
day society yeah but
the actual notion of gender roles yes i
do believe exactly
what you have to do in a relationship
but really i'm just doing that because
obviously it's an exception but my role
is bringing home the bacon making sure
the bills are paid do you think that
well i'm just wondering because what
about girls that make a lot of money
yeah
i mean i'll come in this is the point
you see the problem with that and i i
agree because because you can't be like
oh don't be so productive and like be
too successful
what else are they supposed to do if
they make a lot of money yeah
so feminism had a legitimate complaint
but the wrong solution mm-hmm so
in its
what's that word that you said when the
thing changes the term when the the
trend changes extreme
women want to be boss babes okay it's
great with this empowerment but the
problem is you're going to intimidate so
many men out there
because i'm
he says a lot of men not all men yeah a
lot of men meaning yeah if you're not in
that 10 20 of men that are
essentially so would you guys then
approach a girl that makes more than you
no
you wouldn't would you
in the beginning no but would you no no
if you knew like you know she's very
successful she makes more money ah for
me
for nothing okay
me i personally wouldn't approach her
just because i don't think i'd have the
means to sustain see what if she the
uptake
what if she was into you would you care
look
so now you're saying you're not
approaching them because you're
basically saying it's like she's too
she's out of your reach type thing like
no maybe she's like you're ready but
you're saying like what she's got you
can't maintain or you can't stay with
her i think what he's doing he's
thinking about the long-term things as
well the dynamics of the relationship so
for example let's say i was single and i
met someone was earning six six people
and she was into me
and initially the vibe is good maybe the
sex is good they will move in together
but after that wears away you're
thinking that she's going to respect me
and she's like thinking
i think so no i'm not exactly i think
some girls can do it though to be honest
like i i like the
whitney wolf i want to say like her
she's like one of the fir world's first
female billionaires like like self-made
not through like marriage or anything
she founded bumble and her fiance like
he didn't even know that she was a
billionaire
i like when i talk to most guys they
don't seem to care about a girl's money
it's like nothing to them i see what
you're saying about obviously like the
respect for him but i think like as uh
like when you're a true i don't think
like i'll respect
money like don't get you like it might
attract women like in a sense like
you're flashing bad cash like it might
it might attract bad women but that
don't mean they're gonna respect you
like respect i don't think for most
people can ever be like money so if a
girl gonna respect you you're gonna
respect you like as a man if you've got
less money or more money than i respond
i agree with that a lot because i don't
think like a lot of guys think they can
just no no no no no no i agree with that
a lot because a lot of guys think they
can just get money and all of a sudden
be respected by women and men
and it does
yeah and it doesn't like work like that
like we're not we don't magically become
attracted to you just because you won
the lottery yeah that's true that's true
this is what i was saying before
integrity is your word your bond you
know
do you inspire me do you think made me
feel safe you know this is what i've
always said with guys this is why i
would like
for example
whatsoever so maybe there are four and
they think they can never get a girl
i've always said this work on things you
can't control your integrity
your career your
the way you speak your confidence
that you can um you can work on trust me
that will increase your so if you're a
four i can give you a six
and trust me even a very very attractive
eight convention six if she feels that
this guy's got his stuff on together
[Music]
okay
guys in a relationship like if you're
want to you
dating someone you're a team so
regardless if a guy's making more money
than you or the girl's making more money
that's not forgiveness it's a
togetherness if you're if a girl is
doing better than you yeah she should be
helping you to get up there
you know what will happen is that us
guys we like to feel
you know one of our love language is
words of affirmation we want to thought
we're the greatest thing since sliced
bread
but i don't know that i don't think that
changes yeah but i'm just gonna be there
for example we want to feel that we're
in charge we want to feel it's like
basically you want to keep a man happy
just stroke his ego trust
earns more money then you can still do
that but what will happen is if there's
a major decision that needs to be made
like for example yes yes that's where
the problem comes you see there has to
be a captain you can't have two ceos of
a company and that's where they don't
know but that's why
oh yeah actually i agree with him on
that all right so with the major
decision right if you ever made a major
decision that happens in the
relationship if she's earning more money
for example let's we want to move house
um this house is worth six six hundred
thousand this one's worth five hundred
thousand he's thinking economically i
would have a hundred k more to play with
and she wants that house
and she earns more money
how is she going to say
yeah
or how's she going to listen to him and
go yeah we'll take that house over the
house that she wants
when you have the woman earning more
than a man and stuff
yeah well that's why they talk about
like women can still date down but they
have to like still submit to the guy and
like that's and i think it's harder
i think they're right it's harder when
you make more money but i think the girl
just has to still look up to the guy as
like more competent than her in
something so it might not be money but
it's like maybe he's in a harder like
okay let's say i made a ton of money off
of youtube right and i married an
engineer
like he's smarter than me like i would
absolutely respect his like he's like
because i could never be an engineer
yeah yeah so if you were in that
position
potentially earning more money than the
guy you're right would you sabotage that
or would you actually take it
but it's because no because he's saying
that if a woman earns more she doesn't
respect the guy
but
down the line that could be a potential
banana scale i'm gonna say always okay
let me ask you this
if a woman has the potential of earning
more than her partner
should she sabotage that just because of
the relationship in the future or should
she actually take that yeah i think
there's context to it it depends what
stage you are in the relationship for
example if the kids are grown and left
near an empty nester that may not be a
problem but what if kids are involved
now
and you're thinking to yourself okay
you'll earn you want to do this to get
this venture um big money but you're
willing to put our kids in child care
that could be a potential problem you
see so i've always said this though
women can have all what they want but
not at the same time
it's in different stages in life so for
example if you want to go for that
career have your children once they've
gone through the
their
primary school and their secondary
school to defend for themselves then you
can probably go for that career and you
know earn that six figure salary but you
can't have it my parents
can't come and work that together
yeah you could do it
these are the things that this is well
because you can't it's it's tough to
have everything yep and this is the
thing okay i actually i came from a
family where like my parents did have
everything and because like my mom and
my dad both earned like six figures and
they both like they did very very well
in their careers but like here's the
thing everything comes at a cost and
that's the thing like we tell women that
there is no
cost so like my mom and my dad there
were times where we really didn't see
them a lot they were gone we had nannies
and like we had a lot and that was the
cost and you know it's fine i don't i
don't have any college debt so i'm not
complaining
i am not complaining but like like
everything in life comes at a cost you
can't have everything so if if you
choose to go the career route and you
have a nanny or daycare or childcare
like there are times when your kid's
going to feel closer to the nanny than
to you that's the cost is that worth it
for me yeah like honestly
honestly look at i see my friends paying
off college i got none like cooked we so
for me yeah i'm like i'm never gonna
complain about that but like but like
that that's still a cost
and it's
i think they're gonna be problems either
way like even on like don't know that
like you're
but i just think like like
there has to be a solution for girls
that earn a lot of money yeah you can't
you can because because the the solution
like like the
solution more of a compromise like well
the
the is the solution more of a compromise
of course everything's a compromise
so so let's have a compromise yeah so
like what what is a girl supposed to do
if she makes a lot of money like can i
also say something
you got already you've already she's
making more money you've got a rating
i think
when i look at my rule like i may say
like i may not approach a girl but
doesn't mean i wouldn't date one i think
it's just situation and circumstance
like if the vibe is right and we can
kind of talk it out have a conversation
see where we're at see where we're both
going and like if it could possibly work
out then i'd be open to it well and the
other thing is you have to take into
account personality differences and
personality traits so like even if i was
making a lot of money oh my god if a guy
could take care of the finance stuff i
would be so excited i hate looking at
that stuff
like no but it's also because if i take
a personality test i'm 70 70th
percentile in agreeableness so like like
the the problem is usually associated
when women make more money they tend to
be more masculine and disagreeable
so like it's a masculine trait that
tends to make more money it's not always
yeah but that's so then they end up
single and childless and depressed and
there's a reason for it you see because
with us men we have what we call
boxes we can divide ourselves so we can
be very very assertive on the football
pitch
at home men can do that will smith is a
classic example oh
but with women women can't divide
themselves you see so what their what
they are at work are going to be more or
less what they're going to be at home
you see so that's the that's the
difference but i just think most girls
that i know that are like that they're
just like that like
that's again i don't feel like people
change that much like i think most of
the people i know that were super
masculine when we were kids they're
still pretty masculine now and like i
think people's core doesn't really
change that much
but it seems like the girls that are
really masculine always end up with like
betas yeah
that's what that's what they'll be like
[Music]
man why don't you stay up
[Music]
okay i'm gonna read some super chats
real quick so um zentianz in his best
southern oh no
in his best southern accent pearl i
don't know if anyone else hears this but
the guest in the red shirt and the two
ladies have a have an echo um
audio to hear but they don't speak
directly in the mic so guys when you
turn this way you need to make sure like
you still talk into the mic okay because
when you're turning like you're not into
the mic and then it picks up okay that
way okay yeah
um so okay i don't want to feel like i'm
breathing inside no
this is how you should be here it's cool
yeah
i watch a lot of podcasts so yeah i
understand that yeah um okay um and then
amen dana i see people aren't working on
the relationship part of their lives
with purpose or intent is it because the
resistance of traditionalism caution to
the wind and or carefree or feel fear of
failure
slash nerves um i think that
birth control gave people more options
and i think there's a lot of personality
differences in the population and on top
of that i think feminism kind of
influenced that kind of sold women like
a false bill of goods as well very true
do you do you guys agree with that
the do you think um feminism
like
have you ever felt like lied to by
feminism at all was that a train you
ever got on
like when they were talking about
um
you can have it yeah you can have it all
[Music]
i don't know
i don't know
they have never identified themselves as
feminists so no
no they seem quite traditional
to some degree
no i just was curious
yeah of course yeah
can you can you can you
can you cook can you can you fix up can
you fix something
[Music]
like i'll get it can you change your
battery in the car my kitchen batch with
my phone yeah of course sometimes
obviously
and a charger get a good one
now there's a lot of things like them
things like i'll get it done but like
right now it's like
threw me on the side of the road like
without no instructions
there's youtube
i'm just saying like there's a lot of
things like right now like if a light
went out like off rip like i ain't going
to say that i can fix a light bulb give
me an hour on the right equipment yeah
i'll be able to get there
that's what you can ask for i think
that's been resourceful i think if
anything i think that's what i'm part of
masculinity is it's being resourceful
you may not know the answer now but
you're willing to do the research to get
the answer 100 yeah and no i can't i
feel like i have that trait though like
i feel like if i want to fix something
i'm going to fix it like me personally i
i like diy like i'm going to get it done
okay
that's good
it has to be done
whether it takes me three hours one hour
or two seconds it's good good quality
good quality yeah but you know
i'm the same where i always figure [ __ ]
out i always like better because then
you know that knowledge it's going to
stick with you okay i know how to do
that
if it's done this way something else
might you know yeah it's even like let's
go ahead guys i'm also quite impatient
so asking someone else to do it i
wouldn't want to wait on that
can i fix it myself
oh gosh i can't fix anything i just felt
like i just felt like with like what i
want to figure [ __ ] out like even with
the show like i don't know how to do any
of this and you just like kind of figure
it out along the way
you know what i mean 100
like oh my gosh there's a time where i
only like recruiting people is so hard
but it's gotten so much easier the last
couple months
that's always good yeah
um you've got persistence that's good
good quality
a lot of people would have said this too
hard now
and stop but it's that push that will
keep you going really
okay so question do you think
um who do you do you think women lack
femininity today
it needs to be a bit like a seed
if you want the seed to grow it needs to
have the water the right environment the
right temperature and the seed will grow
in the same way with women if they don't
have the environment in front of them to
cultivate that it's not going to believe
in conditional femininity
no i believe that the environment it's
like a seed if you just put a seed in
just on the floor like that nothing's
going to happen that's what i think will
happen with our modern day society it
hasn't got the
environmental factors to help cultivate
that so that the seed's gonna do
whatever it's gonna do you see because
naturally human nature is toxic in
itself
so without that so i'm just i don't
understand
so so i'm saying like do you like do you
you it sounds like you're saying like
women aren't feminine because they're
not in the right environment like that's
what it sounds like you're saying no i'm
saying for the feminine
i believe women do have that feminine
equality but it needs to be cultivated
okay and how would it be cultivated the
right environment because it's quite
ashamed like a society that uplifts
femininity okay and society that
obviously
you think because like the culture
doesn't push it that's why we're lacking
femininity okay what
what is like what we're saying is like
femininity like for them not to look
like a tomboy type thing no no no
it's kind of like the masculine like
the girls that are like
arguing super heavy like i don't know
how to describe it but you can just tell
when they're
like super man's piece yeah so that's
femininity yeah better man's piece
being submissive being able to
uh how can i put it bring out the
softness of a man so for example a man
goes out to work and he's fighting all
different actors here here and there he
wants to come home and say oh honey
decompress his food on the table so he
feels like i can relax he doesn't want
to come home to the woman's arguing
again for the first time he comes in by
that sort of thing so if so like based
on that femininity is like a woman like
providing for his man no
woman being he's the man's piece
okay yeah so femininity is more of like
acts and
what like
like acts of service acts of service but
also just being a woman just being proud
of i'm willing to you know take care of
my man making sure he's
femininity qualities or attributes
regarded as characteristics of women
it's like very broad how is femininity
defined the quality or nature of the
females that sex the quality state or
degree of being feminine or womanly
challenging traditional norms about
femininity and that's a typical
university initially if said femininity
i would have said like i'm not gonna
cook food because of this this this yeah
i just feel like the girls that aren't
feminine are arguing all the time like
they're just like looking to like oh
like he has to cook for me because no no
it's like the girls that are like
aggressive with guys you know i mean
like they're they're like
yeah yeah no i don't know i don't get
that like energy either of you but yeah
[Music]
do you think that um men lack
masculinity today
and you're in your experience oh
with the energy masculinity what is that
so
not being able to put his foot down
or not being able to tell me look sort
this out yeah
what do you think it is um no i know i
kind of get i know what it is but it's
just like i feel like
most men have it in them
to to kind of put their foot down it's
like they're scared they'll do it the
way they do it yeah but then again at
the same time wrong one thing i would
sympathize with our sex in terms of why
we're not masculine well we
find it hard to be masculine because
we're scared of cancer culture so for
example if i open the door for a woman
who will say why are you opening the
door for me you shall finish pig has
that happened no that's a lot that's a
lot that's a lot yeah but men
if you know your place like i'm opening
the door for you so you can go through i
will tell you that
open the door walk through it again
that you shouldn't be scared if you're
going to do something do it with your
chest because you're going to do it yeah
if you don't want to do it yeah don't do
it yeah but for example i don't know if
you've seen this there was a situation
whereby this wife um went on tick-tock
to complain that her husband and her
stepfather her father-in-law
per request for her to clean the house
they were building she went difficult to
say
can you believe it my husband and my
father-in-law have told me to clean this
mess the video went viral
and for the wrong reason yeah you go
girl how can you tell to do that a
couple of weeks later the woman got
divorced
because she complained
about that
but that's the power of social media
right there yes but you know what it is
she went to socials though
women gas women into doing things that
women should do that they wouldn't do
you know
if a girl goes to a group chat or
whatever like some issue
or the girl are going to say like a
madness but then if it it happened to
them individually yes they're not
understanding that energy
that's what we have
oh my gosh no because a guy called her
earlier and like he said she was like he
was like she's only acting like this
because you're here
she was like oh you just pretending i
was like what are you talking about i
hate stuff like that it's like yo i'm
losing you guys you don't think it's
true so so a guy a guy like called her
that you hadn't spoken to in a while
in like a year and a bit yeah and
there's a random call and i was like and
she in the world and he's like asking
her out yeah and she's like what the i
haven't heard from you in a year i
haven't heard from you and now all of a
sudden you want to demand all this time
you know what i'm saying you can't come
to me with that why how wait what where
yo
why
the fact that you've been what do you
mean while you're in college
how am i supposed to be like oh you know
what let me just drop everything i'm
doing for you not everything just like
one evening no
are you sure i just think you're
defending it probably just think girls
are difficult yeah in a sense of like
okay a guy just basically like
build her build your line basically
saying like yo can i take you out on a
date no yeah but you don't want to do it
yeah but look at the context though this
guy hasn't
been contacted
have you asked him why have
the reason i didn't even so you know
but how do you know he's confused about
you might be going for a bad time in his
life okay he said that communicate that
obviously don't just come out nowhere
just be like i need you now
and now see it's tough you see we talked
about it
because obviously
is it lower is less demanding is oh my
god i come to a realization like i miss
you
i should have been doing xyz it's not
nothing
well it just it just sounds like he's
full of [ __ ] because where have you been
did you not miss me in the past year
i feel like he was on his phone
scrolling through his contract
okay okay let's say there's a chance
that i'm doing it
is there also never a possibility that
this guy was maybe like a nice guy he
was going through some like serious
issues like and because of them issues
he was confused about what he was able
to give you and delivered to you a year
and a half ago he's he's improved in his
situations in his life he's better now
and now he feels like he's at a place
where he's like i want to take you out
and start up what we had again where was
that communication in what he said okay
but let's say feel something that mad
something mad happened in his life where
he was really struggling already men are
in a place where they aren't able to
communicate their feelings and he wasn't
able to communicate his feelings but
right now he's reaching out to you to be
able to try communicate his feelings try
to get back on the basis
i think that's more of a possibility i
think it could be a possibility yeah but
probability watch and the way yeah the
probability is low oh low it's slow yeah
yeah yeah very slow
exactly we got food coming so you might
as well say grab a little bite to eat
have a little chat on the ones and twos
i would keep it pushing or keep it
moving like
obviously live your best life in it like
i'm just a peacekeeper
[Music]
don't don't call him back i've never met
him i'm saying we've never met before i
think he asked dude
that was my reaction too
he has to hunt he has to show his worth
now
why do you guys think that men are
taught how to treat women but women
aren't taught how to treat a man let me
ask that question again but loudly why
why do you think
why
do you why do you think that men are
taught how to treat women but women
aren't taught how to treat a man
but i don't think that men are really
taught how to treat women though
you know what she got a point
i don't think men are taught how to
treat a woman i i think you always hear
about like men stepping up men men men
paying for dates
men
men
men being by society then
yeah by society but if you say like if a
girl goes on tick-tock and says i want a
man who's a provider all the girls will
say yes you should get that but if a
girl if a guy gets on tick-tock and says
i want a woman who can cook they'll say
they'll they'll tear him down why would
you want that
no but girls can do it in a not nice way
like i don't want to like
like what's the song um i don't want no
scrubs yeah
we sing that
like you can't say that's not in our
i culture find it but it was a tweet
from our old homie economics book from
the 1950s that says how to keep your
husband
and one of the things it said when he
comes back from work give him at least
30 minutes please make sure the house is
clean make sure this is that you would
never see that happen to the heat when i
saw that
what happened
i mean it does happen yeah but
there are good women out there do you
know any
no there's a couple
there
my beautiful friend over here like good
women are still out there no i but i
agree and i think it's more like i'm not
even talking about
yeah i'm not even talking about like
like individual households like i think
that like there are a lot of good women
and i think that individually in the
culture do you know what i'm saying yeah
yeah but i'm what i'm talking about is
the culture yeah like i'm not talking
about individuals yeah
because
the coach is not like
to
do that the culture's all about like
what like a man can do for you yeah it's
never about like
even like songs and stuff like that it's
not about like what a woman's gonna do
it's all about if a man's either
certified or if you ain't and what man's
gonna do for you like talking about when
girls are singing whatever it's like
what a man can do it's not about like
what a girl's gonna do so it's just like
it's some breaded like girls expect
everything and not doing nothing even
now with like
the growing
the grown-ness in like what women
are meant to do or whatever
or like what they're allowed to do but
they still want the
traditional vacation stuff of the men
they were somewhat meant to do this to
do that but when men were doing that
there was an expectation from the women
but now men are still meant to do that
but aren't allowed to expect that from
the women because it's meant to be like
rude or whatever so like
yeah getting changed crazy women it just
seems like in in society whenever men
say like this is a standard for me like
women want to tear it down
like like if they say oh i don't i don't
want to date like someone that's
overweight
like torn torn down torn down
immediately but if girls say i don't
want to date someone that's a bomb like
it's accepted it's accepted like why is
that i think it's the systematic
teardown of the man in the household
it's the idea that um in order for the
system to get
what they want um they have to
take the man away from the top of the
household the way to do that is to kind
of
push the idea and the agenda that
women need to be independent
feminists
um at its highest level um and all of
these factors that
like and i don't need a man men are
trash
that's so common but it's so it's so
strange to me because i always ask this
question like if guys are saying okay
well women are [ __ ] like how would
people wrong misogynist how how it grows
that's a very big word like yeah it's
trash but
dehumanizing your opposite sex yeah
just don't
you know what yeah
does it affect women more men
more psychological perspective that's a
good one
the answer is simple effects men both
well more likely to go into depression
if we want to blood than women are
because women get unimpressed she can do
other things she can look after child
care for other people do this she would
that's why we commit suicide that's
what's hot that's what it is it's the
equivalent
when you say hot because obviously if a
woman is class as a whole or promiscuous
no one wants to know she's the
you know she's the uh what you call it
the prior of the community but if a man
is useless he is part of the community
and he gets let go so both words are
toxic yeah
very toxic yeah i agree with 100
which is why it shouldn't
i don't think like anyone should kind of
own it then
i've never heard a guy call himself
trash
i have i have really hundred percent in
the states but a lot in the year
like a joke like kind of like
picking themselves up because they're
trash oh so it's like they're bragging
about treating girls like trash yeah
it's like they've they're able to do
this i heard women calling themselves
too yeah i mean so it kind of works both
ways that's what i'm saying if you're
owning it then it's different if you're
telling yourself like yo i can do this
and i'm trash then then if someone calls
you trash you're gonna be like yeah i'm
what do you know what i mean so don't
don't only if that's not the persona you
want to have true let's start campaign
and toxic words like thrash and holes
what if it's true
[Music]
yeah what if it's true like call a spade
a spade or not yeah
i think it's like that
isn't that a bad point
that shouldn't be used as your identity
this uses a state so for example this
period of time my behavior is fresh but
i can change but when we identify that i
am fresh no matter what i do that's when
toxicity comes if you murdered four
people yeah 20 years ago yes
are you a murderer yes you are yes okay
yes one well but i think
but i think that's different that's
different than calling like women or
hoes
or men are trash that's an entire group
of people i say like the whole of the
gender now
save me
i think guys have a like yeah you can
call spade a spade like just like just
like girls can say okay he's he's uh
players yeah like if the guy is so like
some guys are trash you know so if
they're trash and if a female
be a spade like the same like like if
they are trapped and like yeah i think i
feel i think what language you should
use their behavior
just saying that they're fresh no matter
what they do
[Music]
i'm sorry if this dude has cheated on
every single girl he's been with his
behavior yeah i agree no i would say
he's i'm sure he's trash i think what
i'm trying to do i'm just trying to
dissect they're lying like i didn't no
there ain't no dissecting like you you
are you are your
actions i'm gonna be a superstar and
tomorrow i become a superstar i have now
put that into action i've made it a
thing
so in the same way i think there's
certain positive behaviors that you've
done to contribute to be for you
becoming a superstar all i'm just saying
is i think it's to do with
with
why we suffer from a mental health
crisis because we've lost what our
identity to our true identity is we
identify with our negative side so we
think i did this i failed my exams once
that's
i just think people's core don't change
like it goes back i really think like
like if you're a cheater like the odds
of you being monogamous in a 50 your
marriage is probably low sorry if you've
cheated in the last two relationships
you've been in
how are you gonna stick it out in the
next one
like it's the same thing with a girl
like if she's be sleeping with everybody
how the hell are you gonna stick it out
through a 50-year marriage
like i i
i don't know so you think a woman that's
like so like let's say a woman based on
that would like a high body count or
something
do you think they and maybe if they've
cheated like in the past do you think
they can ever be faithful
i think it's it's harder for them
statistically like every every study
like a girl that's slept with more so if
you are a virgin and you're a girl and
you get married you have a 30 chance
of or 80 chance sorry of having a happy
marriage but it goes down to 30 if
you've slept with more than five people
um
it's like practically they're they're
slightly higher if they're a virgin but
it's practically the same yeah men are
different men are different it's it's
not like it just is what it is
and like that's why like as much as
women want to erase like body count and
say it doesn't matter it does is yeah
and
i don't want to say like i am christian
i'm not like a crazy christian i don't
go to church every weekend like not like
that but i do believe that once you find
god
you and you are you're in a marriage or
you're in a relationship where god is
like the main focus
those problems aren't really there yeah
you know you know you don't if you're
like if you really have that connection
with god and i don't mean to go to
church i don't mean like all these
i think it's an exception rather than
the rule and that's actually a mating
strategy by women
so like women want when they want to
like up their value they basically like
like that's what they do they find god
and it's usually around the ages of like
27 to 29.
no no it's a mating strategy so like
basically to up their value to a guy
they go to church they say they found
god and all the stuff i did before is
washed away and now i and now and now
i'm like born again and they might not
even say they're and i think i think
you're right there are some people that
truly do
but like
it's it's kind of crazy because rolo
tomasi breaks it down in his book but
like it's literally around the ages of
like
27 to 20 like to 30s like early late 30s
that like women find god when they're
trying to remarket themselves
i agree with you i just think it's more
exceptions
in terms of that so for example let's
say someone who's
basically had a whole face finds a guy
and tries to make it work i think
forgiveness doesn't necessarily
equate to um consequences just because
you've been forgiven existence doesn't
mean that you haven't that you won't
suffer the consequences yeah he tells
the he tells the baby mamas to wait till
they're married
so they wait till that's what you said
in the last show i said the the baby mom
the baby mamas should wait till they're
married make the new guy wait until he's
married
they're going to be ending they're going
to go away no way that's what i said i'm
like he just wants them to be by
themselves
like that's better for a family come on
look no i i understand your premises but
like theoretically
yeah that's what like
look at her and be like wait but you had
a child why are you gonna
and the way you look at it is you look
at it as like oh that's the consequence
okay what about the result what about
what's best for the kid what's best for
the future yeah
she didn't ask to be in that
say oh i had that kid before i became a
christian like he doesn't belong to me
that's that responsibility to that kid
that's what i'm trying to say you should
never like deny a child regardless of
anything yeah well how do you not think
it's the like i feel like baby mama's
like put themselves in that like it's
their own fault they put themselves in
that situation
because okay i just don't like we have
so many forms of birth control you can
track your cycle you can only get
pregnant like five days in a month it's
very likely pregnancy yeah and then you
have the option to get an abortion or
give it up for adoption but then
now you kind of know what you want in
life right whether you want the child or
not
but it's it's it's can have a situation
that was a like had arise before you
didn't go in it to be like yeah i'm just
going to be a single mom forever like
this it's because they were
irresponsible like if you get an iud
like your chances of getting pregnant
are very slow say if you were a single
mom and on top of that on top of that
like rubber like you can use condoms
yeah let's see if you were like a single
mom uh-huh would you not want
a man in your life to be like you know
to cater to you and make you you know
what i mean feel like you are of value
even though you do have a child
would i would i want that yeah i just
don't think it's realistic
like that's like we don't live in like a
fairy tale where like they'll just
forget you have a child yeah it's a big
ass yes it is a big ass for us men to
look after another man's seed in animal
kingdom she look at the
lion the lion will eat the cubs of the
previous male thing and you know
yeah so so it is that's why i do raise
stepfathers who do
yeah praise quite frankly you know and a
lot of people the red pill community
called them but i think they're actually
heroes
what's an iud before we carry on
it's a form of birth shouting yeah thank
you what's the red pill
oh the red
it's like the sector of youtube i'm in
so it's like where we talk about this
stuff okay okay but i just i don't
understand you can't have an accidental
pregnancy in this day it's because of
you being irresponsible
like if you if you are on birth control
you you track your cycle you're young as
well like we have young moms and young
teen moms out there as well that may
have not had the guidance
no but there's so many
like you have the internet any any kid
can figure it out isn't in the uk
sorry every kid like i'm saying like
you're exposed to [ __ ] so young now with
the internet like you if you really want
like sex ad or to learn about birth
control like you google it yeah but
maybe they have learned about sex but
not birth control yeah oh come on i i
have a sister i have sisters that are 13
14 15 they know what birth control is
they're not stupid
too many excuses yeah people know that's
just like taking away accountability
i'll tell you i'll say one thing though
like with birth control like me
personally i'm against women taking and
putting things in their body
to
maintain birth control just purely
because i wouldn't do it myself and i'm
not talking from an equality standpoint
i'm talking from a standpoint of
do you know what that's actually doing
to your body the side effects the side
effects
i know people that are like talk about
their hormones or girls are specifically
talk about their hormones and how like
it it's like have affected them it's
affected them they've got they've got
pains that they didn't have before and
i'm like i feel so bad for them because
i'm like
did you understand the consequences of
the actions that would have well they're
given it so young
but even out without birth control like
condoms
that's it people act like that's not an
option no i hit him
that's a good question though why do
guys think that
that's not an option like why why do
girls not tell guys to use condoms or
you know force them to use a condom they
really want to sleep with each other
like some guys are really against it and
they won't use a condom well then don't
sleep with them
[Music]
because you're not thinking about the
future they're ahead the woman being a
single mom you're thinking in this
moment right now when it brought you
yeah exactly yeah
yeah yeah you have to be responsible for
the entirety of what's going on
yeah
i literally think if a girl gets
pregnant it's like all on the girl and
not even on the guy
and yes because because because like
we're just in control of everything like
we're in control of birth control we're
in control of sex we're in control if
the kid gets born
like like maybe maybe not pregnancy but
birth we're in control of like any like
the guy has no say in abortion
i think to an extent
90
is woman oh yeah you guys can trap women
as well guys guys contract women yeah
women control
nope ow
oh not really i mean you've got even if
a man attempted it or she needs to just
go on youtube or tick tock and i'm
showing the guy and the guys get
canceled anyway that's all she needs to
do
what an error
i think it's hard for her i mean it's
hard but it can happen but like if a guy
did like if you did sleep with someone
like that and that happened couldn't you
just take a hill
like the next day you're like oh no
whereas
the other way around like
i can't force on blog you need to take
this yeah and plus
you have girls you know like in drake's
situation
you know yeah do you think that's child
support 18 years i don't know do you
think that should be illegal
it is quite clever from the woman doing
that
no but that's so silly no it does
financially i'm not saying it's right
but it's clever she's thinking i'm gonna
get 18 years of income
[Music]
how would you structure the child
support laws to better advocate for men
because on one hand like
i do think they should have you know
like like there should be some
responsibility if the kids the moms
taking care of them more at the time
like weekends or something but at the
same time like what like that should be
illegal you should not be able to make
like 20k a month on child support i'm
not in the situation so it's hard to say
but i think like above like a certain
like income and i think that inc income
should be close enough enough to just
like maybe just above
standard where like
just above stamp i think once you get
past that sound or like
it should just be like a fixed rate so
like whether you make 33 or three mil i
feel like that rate should be fixed
because what about if the child just hit
like 18 after that
would you still be paying or not nope
well i just feel like
the
whatever whether the guy makes three mil
or let's say 33. obviously if the guy
makes less than that yeah then maybe it
should be less because of taking account
the yeah and that he might not be able
to eat so maybe it doesn't mean i think
after
maybe whatever is 30 or whatever so like
you know you can give
to the woman so they can do the child
but you're still gonna be able to eat i
think it should just be a flat rate
because it shouldn't be if someone makes
like
seventy seventy thousand or someone
makes thirty thousand
a child
from the mother's side is gonna cost the
same like obviously if when you have
custody like you can do as you please
now you can spend more on it but
for the woman like
i think it should just be like they get
the money that they need like they
shouldn't have to live yeah um
yeah
i think it should depend on how much the
guy makes and then like a certain
percentage of that i don't believe in
this fixed-rate thing
if the guy makes i don't know 30 million
a year then you should get a percentage
of that and it'd be oh my god why
i believe something
that she has she has she has got a good
point on that as well i think it's
depending on a guy that's making 30
million a year or let's say i don't know
10 million a year he lives a different
lifestyle than somebody that has oh
right right but but then one issue but
the issue you're going to run into is
like
are those moms really spending it on the
kids no save the money girl make sure
you save that invest that money so you
can build your business no but you but
that's not but that's not accurate
that's not what's really happening like
women don't women don't typically save
money
like women actually have more like like
three times the amount of debt as matt
you're helping the lifestyle for the kid
as well like the guy's gonna build his
own lifestyle with his free meal but
so do you feel like that's it should be
have
a lifestyle as well
isn't so but child support is
to support the fees of the child yeah
and the fees give that child okay so the
fees are the check the fees of the child
is
like care whatever like schooling maybe
whatever all of that stuff get the best
books get the best school and if it is
if it is a school like they go to a
school so it's not like when he's
staying with you he'll go to one school
and say i need to go to one school
what i mean is like if if he's like a
richer father then i'm pretty sure if
he's known then that child is probably
gonna go to i don't know private school
which costs more money yeah okay so then
do you have might have security which is
funny yeah that's our little thing that
you should be here yeah so in the
meeting if like together they agree like
okay we want our child to go to this
school
i don't mean much the females i don't
make much money i can't afford that the
guy's like okay i want my child to do
that so i'll pay for that but i have to
see him every but then i don't see why
like
once everything's paid for so like if i
paid directly to the sources so i paid
directly to the school directly to the
pharmacy to get nappies or wherever so i
paid directly to the supermarket for
food i don't see them why i'm also
well not me but i don't see why people
in society like these celebrities are
also paying
their their ex-spouses
or ex
or whatever it is also like ten thousand
a month yeah for them
my love and my loyalty to the kid so
when we've broken up like my loyalty to
the kids not to put you in our house or
put you in a car how have you got that
kid
yeah you know with her for sure
in a safe environment i know but
co-parent that's a major thing yeah but
you're you're incentivizing women to get
bags from these guys like that's not
that's not healthy no it's not like then
do it no no you could say that but like
you have to realize when you create a
law people you have to know that people
will take it to the extreme because
people are crazy and so when you have a
law where women can take advantage of
men you have people stealing like
condoms and on top of that like how many
babies do you think have been made like
this is just one girl that got caught
you don't think girls have been doing
this for decades
like i don't understand like why is a
woman entitled to a guy's money just
because he's rich
the kid is sure but like why does she
like i don't think she should just guess
i think long term you know guard your
seed your precious seed
always facts yes
investment man that's that's c creates
life man yeah i guess the guys gotta be
careful then yeah i agree yes i do
crazy
aren't you the guys that were just
saying guys don't like to wear condoms
i didn't say that i did not say that
i was not talking and i was quiet i
actually was quiet
because you remember there is the brain
when we want to come and there's the
brain postcard when we uh we'll when our
eyes are post not clarity yeah force
that clarity comes you see
like you know what you're thinking in
that moment you know what you're gonna
think not really what's fun they just
want to get the bag yeah but then think
about no stop thinking before then
because then that means easier said than
done can i can i say something
no
it really is it really is and i'll
explain
so
the point i'm going to make is like
women have it where like their post not
clarity is 24 7. so if they yeah no
honestly so if they're in a situation
where like they're meeting up with a guy
and they're having conversation and
whatever they're able to keep a level
head because they know what they want
where they're going to get or how
they're going to get it yeah whereas a
man yes
before yeah free nut yeah is thinking
his head's going all over the place he's
trying to keep it calm yeah and he's
trying to control himself yes once it's
post not yeah there's clarity yeah the
same clarity that you had for the 24
hours
drawing before and after
okay i disagree i feel like
it depends where a girl is in her cycle
because when a girl is ovulating it's
very so those five days
what about the the rest you're right
you're really good
you're good
you're right you're right
so we saying dirty i still i just i feel
like as a guy you should have the
self-control to not hook up with these
hoes wrong
i'm sorry
i'm starting like
okay we understand how you feel but you
can interrupt
that's why women are able to exploit us
or men that are at that kind of point
where it's like but guys like that like
i mean drake would look he was wearing
one
like why would you clever like why would
you put yourself in that situation he's
like being smart he's now putting hot
sauce in his thing isn't it oh no he is
i'm not like the app like other yeah
that was too small
like i don't know
that's interesting i have a super chat
okay um sentience 50 bucks um
[Applause]
he's always energy yeah always okay
please stop the lying the benefit the
child comes second to the mother if if
it comes at all in the u.s 66 of child
support goes to the courts then the rest
is given to the mother who in turn uses
it as her income for the woman second
super chat another 50 bucks from
sentience for the women who said guys
don't like to work count condoms how
about some accountability you as the
female chose who you get who gets
between your legs and when they do you
decide if they wear a condom or not
lastly you choose their birth control to
use i i agree with you but i'm just
saying stop hooking up with these hoes
raw like
it's more of the girl's fault what do
you guys think about the child support
yeah because what he said at the end of
the day it's the court system what do
you guys think
well i personally don't know how
well
i didn't think i had much child support
i don't know i don't know how it
actually like
i'm not sure but like assuming let's
just assume it's the same here if it's
the same here would you
because
sixty-six percent goes to the question
goes to the court
yeah i didn't know that to be honest
that's a bit yeah so essentially
[Music]
that we're in so
that percentage is going to now yeah so
ideally it should be your local
community if there is a divorce or a
separation your local community should
mediate to sort it out yeah
there has to be some
like
it's hard because i don't actually know
what a good solution would be because i
i do part of me feels like there should
be some protection for like kids where
the one parent like doesn't want to be
involved yeah like they really should
but at the same time like people are
exploiting that so what do you do
could it be so how
i'm just throwing this out there right
there in there
i ain't saying this is
the idea of my solution but what if like
if there's a situation where like
obviously like mid-pregnancy or like
when it first got mm-hmm first what
happened if a if a male was able to
basically say like
i'm not down for this pregnancy
basically
if you sound like a legal document
and then that was it being able to give
to the woman so based on that she's able
to say like
i can make the decision to have this
child
or not but if i do i'm going to be by
myself having a child i actually agree
with you because women have the right to
an abortion yeah you know that's only
for like a few months right
[Music]
[Music]
so
that's a long time yeah but so so that's
a long time for him to make up his mind
still if he wants to be with me no but
if if it's just like i didn't want the
child or whatever so there's a legal
document you can sign send it to the
courts or whatever yeah yeah before so
like two months in and you get that
document
and then so you can see in this document
it's like i can go through with it but
based on this document i'm gonna have to
go through with okay raising the child
by myself
because because i feel i if a guy if a
girl has the right to say i don't want
to be a parent i think guys should have
that same right
so if in the first four months she can
say i don't want to be a parent like why
does the guy not get that right
financially because men
because men and women are different
i i think of it like a woman being a
lock and a man being a key right
a master key can open many locks but a
cheap lock can be opened by any key
i say that again say that again say that
again reload
[Music]
i'll say it one more time so a master
key can unopen any lock but a cheap lock
can be opened by any key
in this scenario men be in the key and
girls being the lock
if if you chose to open those locks or
open that specific lock right you have
responsibility
over what you open up and what you
uncover
like where do we go without wait
time
oh no no i just i just believe in like i
believe in like equal rights under the
law
so legally like so i just think if
personally in my in my world like i
don't believe in abortion like so
and in my world like that would just be
illegal like they wouldn't that we
neither would have any rights in that in
that sense but i'm saying if we're gonna
give women the right to an abortion
which is what we do like why can't men
have the same right to not be a parent
like women do like women can
you know be like have they want i know
people that have had like three four or
five abortions yeah like i've heard
stories like that so they can keep doing
it so why can't men keep signing off on
the rights
to being a parent because both sisters
are broken
but it's like that is it
within that nine months of me carrying
that baby that guy could have been with
nine other girls like it's deep yeah
it's deeper than what yeah right but but
you but you also see women using
abortion as a form of birth control
today
you see like every every girl every i
know multiple girls that have had
abortions each and every single one of
them they were being irresponsible they
weren't on birth control they weren't
any form of birth control they weren't
even pulling out okay well so
yeah so so that's what i'm saying they
were using that abortion as a form of
birth control
that's deep
so so it's like if women if women can do
that like why can't men freaking sign
off on their rights too
like why and why can't why can this girl
legally take like take drake's seed and
impregnate herself like that that
happens all the time
it's tough you know why it's gotta be
wise up these days man that's what i'm
saying
okay i have a super chat um you coming
for me sentience oh my god on the
abortion thing something like sauron
said i got this from sarah the most
aborted babies in the world are from the
black community um
yes it is we're the most aborted race
well it's tough to say man you know we
like to say
as a guy you should have the
self-control to not be with those 304s
that's asking a starving man to not eat
the food in front of it
because it is rotted
some men get out here starving and they
take what they can get look at
okay you can you can absolutely take
what you can get but there's going to be
consequences and if i had a son i would
tell him to be careful yeah
um guys you're precious and you can you
can still hook up with the 304s but like
wrap it like
wrap
um i think i'm gonna end the show though
on that so um why don't you go around
and everyone um
tell them where they can find you okay
my name is indy my instagram is ini1983
and add me there please thank you
and josh i'm an instagram twitter
jayward hibber
my name is anaya and my instagram and
twitter as well as tick tock are shorty
with the fro
that's amazing
a underscore
j-a-e underscore sorry louisa j
my name's ish you can find me on
instagram at ish
h g w e g w e n i
okay guys um thank you so much for
watching guys as you guys know um all
super chats right now are being donated
towards multiple cameras we might we
might have a producer in here soon
so um
so i really appreciate all the donations
it really helps make the show like what
it's been um so i really really
appreciate all of you another way you
can help support the show
is by purchasing one of the meal plans
that are in the description um it's
cooking with chris and guys i seriously
lost like 15 pounds on this meal plan so
it works you're not you're actually
gonna like the food that you're eating
and you're gonna look better and feel
better so
you know
help help a girl out okay
um okay guys don't forget to subscribe
to the channel oh i got one more super
chat i'm gonna read it before i go
because i will win okay
um halle berry adele and kelly clarkson
are paying alimony and child support
does the women of the panel deem that
fair real quick do you deem that fair
just yes or no wait wait again sorry
okay uh halle berry adele and kelly
clarkson are paying alimony and child
support does the women of the